there's no free sex
it's too dangerous are you speaking
about from an emotional standpoint or
physically physically and socially well
think of consent okay when can you give
consent well what constitutes consent a
whim what if you change your mind what
if you're intoxicated what if you're
stoned
what if you're upset
what if you feel you've been manipulated
and consent is important well what
constitutes consent well marriage does
so that's where sex was encapsulated
fundamentally in the 60s the idea was
that sex could be casual well aids
pretty much put the end to that idea so
and it definitely spread
as a consequence of promiscuity that was
definitely one of the driving factors
that
put aids everywhere so that was
not so good to put it mildly
the reaction on campuses is well
what constitutes consent and the reason
that has become questionable is because
it's questionable
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and the show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
so you talk a lot about malevolence and
i've thought about it a lot and i think
about
these loops and patterns and the way
that we grew up i wonder and maybe the
definition is important of of
malevolence and what you mean harm for
harm's sake so it's intentional it's
aware it's not only intentional the
person who's doing it knows it's wrong
they do it anyway so it's not by
accident this isn't the kind of
patterning or things like that that
drive someone to be reactive or
combative but they're really just
protecting themselves because of
something else going on in their psyche
or in their experience this is someone
who is
mean mean to be mean
yeah they're out to hurt
yeah well i think everybody's like that
some of the time
and some people are like that more often
than others i think one of the best
and we should talk a little bit about
more about self-awareness too because
we didn't quite finish that but
um
resentment can drive that
right resentful you're not getting what
you want you won't admit what you want
you feel oppressed you feel that things
aren't going your way in an unfair way
that can make you want to hurt
it's very powerful motivation
and it's very unfortunate there's more
awareness there but is there not some
level of defense there
no there's revenge
it's more like revenge i mean look that
that defensive reaction occurs i'm not
i'm not denying that at all
so but
i wouldn't consider that malevolence
is
i'm going to hurt you even if i hurt
myself doing it and maybe if i hurt
myself doing it so much the better
oh i've had that on the racetrack before
oh no doubt no doubt of course of course
well and you know if you want to hurt
your parents that's the right way to do
it you hurt them and yourself
and if you don't think people who do
that you just don't know anything about
people i mean
people will do that there's a deep
streak of that capability within us
so
so i i started to understand this a
little bit
in many different ways but you know in
in the story of of adam and eve
adam and eve opened their eyes
right their eyes are open when they eat
the fruit of the tree of
knowledge of good and evil
their eyes are open they notice that
they're naked
and that's when they learn about good
and evil i thought why in the world how
does that make sense their eyes are open
they see that they're naked that makes
sense that that's associated with vision
why would that be associated with the
knowledge of good and evil
well nakedness is vulnerability you
talked about vulnerability
well
malevolence exploits vulnerability
so once i know that i'm vulnerable
i know how to hurt you
right i can use it
and i do think that's something very
specific to human beings i mean animals
hurt each other chimpanzees tear each
other apart
but human beings can be unbelievably
calculated in their use of brutality
and that's because we know what hurts
we have imagination for that and then we
can use it and it's part of being
self-conscious
it's a it's a it's a catastrophic
consequence of being self-conscious you
could think of it that way
so because if i want to imagine how to
hurt you i just have to think well what
would really hurt me if i was in her
situation
and bang i've got it
and i think that's
in some sense it's defensive you know
because people are often driven to
resentment by suffering that they can't
tolerate can't attribute meaning to but
it passes a line
you know when you start adding to it
right
so
and that's something that needs to be
checked and checked in all of us
is there a reason or uh any statistical
research that shows what makes one more
malevolent than another which
or uses uh hurts other people more
well you said second you said um a
hundred times more likely to be step
parent
abused yeah yeah well alcohol does
certainly alcohol being drunk
oh yes i mean alcohol alcohol is a very
bad drug for violence
50 of people who are murdered or drunk
and 50 of the people who murder them are
drunk and that's true for almost every
violent crime in fact if you eliminated
alcohol you'd eliminate most
interpersonal violence
look i i find that this is kind of an
interesting topic because i think it's
interesting that alcohol is legal
and
yet you know you get
you you do terrible things
sometimes you probably couldn't you
probably couldn't have made any a worse
drug legal
right from an epidemiological
perspective on the other hand you have
marijuana or
um
[Music]
psilocybin or
lsd even or some of these other drugs
and they make you thirsty make you laugh
and you wake up feeling fine i find it
really fascinating that alcohol is the
illegal one how did that ever happen
that that or is the legal one how did
why does ours i think it probably
happened because it was so easy to make
and it was just everywhere
right because all you really have to do
is put barley in water and you get beer
right so it was really easy to make and
at least
in many societies it's been around for a
very long time and so it became legal
just because well back in the middle
ages people drank alcohol not water
because all the water was polluted
right right right so
so that's the reason but it certainly
wasn't a consequence of evaluating the
drugs by their comparative risk and rank
ordering them and making you know the
least harmful legal it wasn't that at
all
because alcohol is unbelievably
dangerous i mean about 10 of people
become addicted to it one way or another
really far more people than that abuse
it yes at least once in their life yes
yeah it's really bad i studied alcohol
for years it was my
subject of my phd
oh my goodness so
do you believe that um are you a fan of
the legalizations that have happened
with marijuana and the things that i
don't see that making them illegal has
worked
and i don't think there's good evidence
that legalizing them has had detrimental
consequences
right i mean we legalized marijuana in
canada
just before the pandemic
so the marijuana stores were open
through the whole bloody pandemic
weirdly enough
but
i mean in in terms of interpersonal
aggression
marijuana doesn't even register compared
to alcohol as
a social danger now i'm not saying that
it's without its harm i mean i've i've
had friends who i think were
tilted towards psychosis because of
marijuana and there's some evidence that
it's use if you're predisposed to
psychosis can
can
exacerbate that tendency now he he may
have used it to self-medicate so i can't
say that it was necessarily the cause
but it looked to me like it wasn't good
and i saw lots of people when i was a
kid
for whom pot wasn't good
i saw some for whom it was good
but
many it wasn't it changed them a lot and
not for the better as far as i was
concerned
so what do you think of the therapeutic
side of um
things like psilocybin and the things
that mdma psilocybin that's its own
monster god only knows about psilocybin
yeah i i just
no one has any idea what that is
so i don't know what to say about lsd is
the same sort of thing it's like those
drugs are so far beyond our
comprehension that i mean it takes
almost no lsd it's the most powerful
pharmacological substance ever
discovered it takes a couple hundred
million molecules which is really none
at all to to put you somewhere
completely else
it's it's it's unbelievably powerful
those drugs dmt psilocybin lsd they're i
think they're the biggest mystery
there is
as far as i can tell right now i don't
think there's anything we understand
less than those drugs
marijuana is sort of in that category
because it's a quasi hallucinogen
but
it's not the same sort of thing as dmt
or psilocybin or lsd mescaline
i mean i know that dmt has been called
like the spirit molecule right so
yeah people regularly report you know
encounters with other beings when they
when they take dmt much to the chagrin
and shock of the people studying them
so there's just no one has any idea how
to account for it so it's hard to
account for whether or not there's a
benefit or not to it well
that's a different story to some degree
there was a large-scale study done
population level study of hundreds of
thousands of people who had either used
psychedelics or who hadn't and the ones
who had used them at least once were
healthier by almost every marker
now that doesn't mean necessarily that
you could attribute it to the
psychedelics because there might have
been other differences between the
populations but there certainly was no
evidence that the psychedelic use had
made those people worse
and then roland griffiths and his crew
in at johns hopkins who are doing very
careful studies of psilocybin
have shown that it's extraordinarily
powerful
mechanism for helping people quit
smoking and for overcoming their fear of
death if they have cancer which is
no one you know
why does it help them overcome their
fear well that's a deep mystery that's a
very very deep mystery
so we're probably not going to figure it
out today on this podcast no i don't
think so i i i
i don't think so
so on to a real
on to onto a topic that we probably
could at least unpack a little bit more
and i know that we've got i know that
you've gone down this road before but i
just think that it's
you know i'd love to ask you questions
around it and
it's this
it's it's identity politics and not and
how
it's
is it more rampant than ever i think
it's probably probably
wise to ask if it is or it isn't
basically i think it is well i don't
think that it existed to speak of except
in very localized places 30 years ago
i mean there were racial tensions but
this is a whole different this is a
whole different level of confusion
well you talked about this
you know what's better and what's worse
and you said that there is right right
we didn't talk about what was worse did
we
not accept technological transformation
yeah
with technology and in instability and
so what
what what
is there do you are you aware of
contributing factors that would lead to
people having
climbing on to a concept into a group
and
you know just the the way that the world
is today
i mean it seems well i think i think
to some degree people have always done
that
right i mean one of the purposes of your
society one of its fundamental functions
is to
provide you with a an adult identity
that's what
initiation ritual does
now those are generally more common for
men than for women because women kind of
undergo their own initiation
biologically
right i mean there's a real marker for
maturation for women right right right
and it's pretty graphic
right whereas for men it's more of a
continuum and so in many societies the
males are initiated
um
and
they're terrified to death that's part
of it and then after that they're
given a cultural identity a new adult
identity
well
in our society part of the reason that
identity politics has become so rampant
there's lots of reasons i think but one
of them is that
it isn't
we have a lot of choice
and it isn't obvious that that's all
that good for people
how much choice do you want
do you want to choose your gender
are you bloody well sure you want to
choose your gender
you don't think it's complicated enough
just to take the one that's most likely
suitable for you now we know that that's
an ill-fitting garment
you know there's been tomboys forever
there are feminine men and there are
masculine women
so the gender the gender theorists are
right about that so if you look at
personality which is the right way to
look at it which is not how they look at
it because as as scientists they're
appalling
but there is biological sex obviously
and there is
personality right okay so a feminine
personality i can tell you what a
feminine personality looks like because
we've we've published
i would say some of the definitive
studies
people from my lab
on gender differences and personality
so now i hope i get this exactly right
under extroversion
women are more enthusiastic more
positive emotion
and men are more assertive they're more
likely to dominate conversations those
are both aspects of extroversion the
differences aren't huge
but that's the way they tilt
neuroticism
to be as
sensitive to negative emotion as the
average woman you have to be more
sensitive to negative emotion than 80 of
men if you're male
i think i've got that right i hope i've
got that right it's one standard boat
now it's probably sorry it's not that
high sorry that's not right 60 40 it's
60 40.
so
i can't haul the stats up right away in
my imagination at the moment so anyways
the one of the bigger differences is
insensitivity to negative emotion and
women are more sensitive to negative
emotion
agreeableness
women are more agreeable than men and
the difference is about the same as it
is for negative emotion
so particularly it divides into
compassion and politeness and the
difference is particularly marked with
compassion
so and that might also be responsible
for the explosion of compassion
culture wide
right i mean that's what you see is
right we have to take everyone's
feelings into account
that's compassion
so what are women going to be like
politically
or they're going to emphasize compassion
and perhaps they're going to emphasize
safety
that's what you'd predict if you looked
at the temperamental differences
conscientiousness men and women are
pretty much the same although women are
a bit more orderly and men are a bit
more industrious
openness
pretty much the same
women are a little bit higher in
openness to experience and so that's the
aesthetic end of it which is why they
prefer literature let's say and men are
a little higher in interest in ideas
so those are the differences between men
and women so you could have a masculine
woman she'd have all the masculine
traits now she'd be rarer than a
masculine man by quite a large margin
but it's not so rare that that that
doesn't exist certainly exists that'd be
confusing to some degree because
you know you have a female body and a
masculine psychology masculine
personality
but that why is that a problem exactly
now it's a problem if you can choose
your body all of a sudden
and it isn't obvious see the reason that
i objected in many ways to
what was happening in canada years ago
with the
transgender bill was i thought oh this
is going to confuse far more people than
it's going to help
you know it's not like adolescents
aren't confused about sex and their
identity that's what adolescence is is
confusion about sex and identity
you know in general confusion about
everything what do i do who am i yeah
exactly and no wonder right because you
have a lot of choices ahead of you and
and it's a tumultuous time there's a lot
of neurological reorganization
and so
so it's too many choices
well
look there's a huge literature on
consumer choice so let's say you you
might ask yourself
how many shampoos do you want to go look
at when you're shopping
one
five or three hundred
five five exactly why not three hundred
because one of those three hundred is
the best
diminishing returns on my investment
that's for sure that's for sure and like
how are you going to evaluate 300 items
for quality you just no matter which one
you pick you've made a mistake
you know when you go into subway and you
say they say how do you want your
sandwich like i want you to figure that
out that's why i'm paying for it
you know if i have to make every
sandwich decision i might as well make
it
so so people drown in choice very
rapidly right
talk about anxiety right yes exactly
well that is anxiety it's terrible
anxiety and too many choices is anxiety
so
and
it isn't like i it's not like i know the
answer to how much choice about your
gender you should have
but i think that you know we we need to
recognize that there is wide variation
in personality within women and within
men even though there are differences
and mostly men and women overlap by the
way so we're more the same than we are
different except at the extremes and
that matters
like if you're low in agreeableness
enough one in a hundred let's say you're
way more likely to be in prison
and so that's males
so there are not very many women in
prison
compared to men and
that's because
at the extremes there's a huge
preponderance of aggressive men
physically aggressive men
even though at the middle point there's
a lot of overlap people don't understand
this maybe maybe then the the other side
of the question is then
why are people so offended so easily i
think there's
more difficulty
for each side to speak to each other
people to use the right terminology and
words and not offend someone than ever
too so why why are people seemingly more
easily offended that's a really good
question you know it's it's hard to say
because
people have been offended for a long
time the moral majority was offended for
a long time in the 80s you know i mean
and there was plenty of censorship and
that sort of thing
i
again it's one of those things that's
very difficult to track across time it
might be that we're exposed to more
things that offend us now
i mean you go on the net you if you
can't find something to be offended by
you're not trying very hard well that
could just be it right i mean imagine
that we never want to underestimate the
the impact of insane technological
transformation
you know i mean you can see everything
all the time about anything
and so
i don't know if people are more easily
offended or if there's just way more
offensive things
so maybe it's a matter of just reducing
the amount of options reducing exposure
i mean is this a remedy for clarity for
less
um
volatility less
offensive less less chance to be
offended
well
who knows right i mean twitter seems to
be a good way of being offended
um continually
band offending yeah and you know that
might be a consequence of its structure
it's limited it's it makes it seems to
reward impulsivity
it seems to transmit bad better than
good
quite rapidly we don't know what these
technologies do to people or to
communication
maybe
so i don't know if people are more
easily offended than they used to be
they're offended about different things
more things because there's more things
possibly possibly right i mean it's been
interesting to see what's happened with
with sex over the course of my lifetime
i mean
in the 60s
there was this idea and it was probably
the consequence of the birth control
pill that well maybe sex is is free
right it's free and easy because well
now pregnancy wasn't necessarily a
consequence and venereal disease was
reasonably well under control and so
wasn't a blatant threat certainly not a
fatal one
and so people thought well
why not free love
well i think the reason for that is it's
complete rubbish
there's no free sex
it's too dangerous and so what's
happened is that from an emotional
standpoint are you speaking about from
an emotional standpoint or physically
physically and socially
well think of consent
okay when can you give consent
well you're saying what is we don't know
no under what conditions well what
constitutes consent
exactly
a whim
what if you change your mind
what if you're intoxicated what if
you're stoned
what if you're upset
what if you feel you've been manipulated
you know i mean because the issue of
consent is not if the act is serious
and you can debate about whether or not
that is and people have their
differences of opinion
it's certainly
emotionally
significant in all likelihood
so if it's significant
well then consent is important well what
constitutes consent well marriage does
so that's where sex was encapsulated
fundamentally
because their consent was never an issue
i mean there's all sorts of things that
weren't an issue because of that and it
wasn't like it was a magical solution to
everything but
so you know because
in the 60s the idea was that sex could
be casual well aids pretty much put the
end to that idea at least in part right
so and it definitely spread as a
consequence of promiscuity that was
definitely one of the driving factors
that
put aids everywhere so that was
not so good to put it mildly
and then the reaction on campuses is
well
what constitutes consent and the reason
that has become questionable is because
it's questionable
unless it's not serious but you know
i don't think that people really believe
that
so
they might wish they believed it
but there's plenty of emotional damage
done
as a consequence of
too quick intimacy i think that's
generally the case because in a
partnership that becomes intimate
there's usually one person who's more
emotionally invested than the other
probably almost inevitably yes i mean i
think inevitably in every situation
pretty much yeah yeah yeah pretty much
they can still be very high but
someone's still going to be more than
young
so this kind of leads to the the
conversation about individuality being
the way out of ideological traps
and
and the question is
how
how and what are the ways to know who
you are because i don't think that's i
don't think it's as easy as
it sounds like whoever impossible
people are really complicated
you're way more complicated than
anything else except another person
right you're the most complicated thing
that exists then put two complicated
people together and
yeah well you know hopefully they can
help each other sort themselves out at
least to some degree but yeah i mean
you're
to be self-aware completely is just not
possible because
you know what we try to do to understand
ourselves is
limit what we'll do and you do that to
other people too
say well i know you and then you punish
them if they do things you don't
understand that way they stay in the box
you put them in and there's downside to
that and an upside you know it's part of
the social contract not to do outrageous
things
although you could
so we all abide by these rules and that
simplifies us a lot right right that's
part of being polite is
you don't want the bank teller to be
complex
you want them to be polite and simple
so your limited understanding is
sufficient
and we do that with each other all the
time
except when we're emotional how do you
find the individuality your uniqueness
your specialness
well that probably manifests itself to a
large degree in what you're interested
in which is difficult to know i i think
that's also difficult to know i felt
like it took into my mid-30s before i'm
like oh yeah i'm really interested in
these things
were you interested in all sorts of
things sure yeah when i was young i did
all sports
i
you know then be was a teenager but it
wasn't until i was really in my 30s that
i really really realized how much i
enjoyed
art how much i enjoyed
you know creating and artistic things
how much i enjoyed nature
how much i enjoyed traveling in
alone time because i'm a bit of an
introvert um so it wasn't until i was in
my mid-30s so i figured that out to me
that creates some of my individuality
that's my that's that's who i am
but how do people how do people figure
that out so that they know who they are
so they don't
fall into ideological traps
well so the first question is is
knowing yourself the way out of an
ideological trap well it is to some
degree because
one size doesn't fit all right so you
have to be aware of how you differ
and i that does take a long time to
figure out who you are because you're
complicated
so
it might not be that surprising at all
that it took you till your mid-30s
before you started to have some sense of
who you really were because it's people
are very hard to understand it's and we
don't have a good
vocabulary generally speaking for
analyzing differences in people i mean
that the personality test i described is
a step in that direction and but it's
that lexicon that vocabulary still isn't
popularly established let's say
so it isn't part of the conversations we
have about other people except
accidentally
i produce this other
technology
at self-authoring that helps people
write about their past
analyze their faults and their virtues
and write a plan for the future
it's a useful way of figuring out who
you are you kind of have to hit yourself
against the world but
you know you tell the story about your
past and that that helps you understand
where you came from
you figure out your virtues and your
faults that sort of helps you understand
your strengths and weaknesses and then a
plan gives you a course for the future
it's hard to do all that writing
but it's hard to blunder through life
too without a plan so it's hard either
way pick your heart you always talk
about that choose your choose choose the
difficult or the difficult to choose you
eventually and you might not like it as
much right
yeah well when it's necessary like i
wouldn't say to go to go out of your way
necessarily to make your life difficult
but if you have a difficult choice in
front of you and it's either abandon
what you're you know you should be doing
or do the difficult thing
well you're going to pay a price for
abandonment
so
and i guess i would also say that to uh
to understand yourself it's
quite useful to try to not lie
as you tangle yourself up in your own
lies people think they can get away with
lying but
we you can't get away with falsifying
the structure of the world
you're gonna pay for it i've never seen
anybody get away with anything
in my clinical practice
no something the other shoe always
dropped
always always and unsurprisingly
if you drop a weight on your head above
your head
like it's fine until it hits you
yeah but then there's changing your mind
yeah there you can be wrong that's
different
that's a good point though it's
difficult to dissociate ignorance from
from lying but you know
you get punished when you're wrong often
but that's different you know it's
it's not like it's nothing to be
ignorant to be wrong it's
still
hard on you but it's
different kind of hard to be willfully
wrong when you know better are there
things that you believe differently
today than you did
10 20 30 years ago or when you were
young
oh god yes almost everything
almost everything everything yeah yeah
what's the most recent thing then
well i probably learned in the last
couple of years that i should have had a
broader range of
interests
simple interests because almost
everything i did was really complicated
so then when i got ill i i couldn't do
anything because everything i did was
complicated yeah
so
you wrote this book you wrote you wrote
a lot of
your latest book beyond order
while you were while you were sick right
yes
was that hard
yes yeah
yes it wasn't as hard as not doing it
right
certain level of joy to do it
no nothing was bringing me joy
but
it brought significance it was
meaningful
so
that was useful
but
so what simple things do you like doing
now
oh i don't know if i still can do it i
play ping pong with my son that's good i
like doing that but no i'm not good at
it
so i've walked a lot this year yeah
eight miles a day i relate but i don't
like doing simple things either i i mean
it's i mean
i'm all about deep diving and if the
conversation is surface level it's not
very interesting to me i'd rather just
sit at home alone i'd rather
watch youtube videos of you or somebody
else who's talking about something that
i'm interested in then
then doing something um so that's
openness that's that's the intellect end
of openness the interest in ideas
yeah so that's definitely a personality
characteristic and it can be a profound
one
so being sick really stole
the thing that is the most
meaningful and joyful for you or one of
them
yes yes well it and it i what i really
depended on during that time was my
family and my friends yeah
yeah so i mean i'd always always
regarded them as important but that was
redoubled
during those times yeah
during this time for that matter
[Music]
what has been your biggest trade-off for
the work that you do
privacy
and uh well just too much exposure
and i mean it's funny because i'm doing
podcasts so i'm still exposing myself so
to speak
um but
in some sense that's
just become the way it is
it's the alternative to what i was doing
i was working as a university professor
which i'm not doing anymore so
you know i've do something so this is
what i'm doing and it's not like i mean
i find it very meaningful but
there's this level of exposure that's
beyond comprehension really
permanently beyond comprehension
yeah it's forever for the rest of your
life like this
you know and people have been very good
to me so there's that to be grateful for
but i believe in everything having its
its its ends its polarities and for the
people that you resonate with i'm one of
them why why do i why do you resonate
for me yeah i was going to ask you that
question too because i was looking at my
youtube stats again the other day and
like it's still overwhelmingly male 1
wow and so well i mean youtube skews
male 1 so there's that maybe because i'm
kind of a masculine masculine woman
right like maybe that's part of it i
don't know could there be some sort of
personality
dynamic but
i like how
you have your beliefs and you stand
behind them i respect your uh
your intelligence and your
um
and your depth of knowledge and research
to back it up
like for me that's not something i'm as
good at so i love when someone's done
their research and they have they
believe in what they're talking about
not only in their heart but in their
mind
and i
i love i mean in general the the message
of sovereignty and individuality and
responsibility
i think is an incredible message
yeah the responsibility element has been
well received by people and i think
maybe that's because that message isn't
being delivered as effectively
as it should be the idea that
meaning
meaning is to be found in responsibility
yeah you're saying it happens
you see you're saying it hasn't been it
hasn't been promoted as much well
there's so much of an emphasis on rights
i mean imagine what if our con if our
culture was just dominated by discussion
of responsibility as it was dominated by
discussion of rights
completely i mean that's just not how it
is at all right and that's strange
because
your rights in some sense are my
responsibility and vice versa so
right because your recorded rights
it's distance from other people in some
sense
and for them it's the same and so you
can't have one discussion without the
other
but but our discussion has been very
one-sided and i think that's
hard on people because it's about what
you're owed
yeah and it isn't obvious to me that
i don't know it doesn't it isn't
it's not like not getting what you're
old isn't annoying
it it is if you feel that that an
injustice has been committed but right
it isn't obvious to me that people find
the deepest meaning in their life in
getting what they're owed
i really do think that people find more
significance in their life
in being of you use utility and service
to other people
that's how it looks to me
so
and
often that's discussed in a sort of
should way you know you should be good
to other people it's like well
your life is better if you do that
that's a different way of putting it
and you can get people to think about
that it's like well
remember those times when you were when
people were particularly
happy with something that you did
something for them
how did you feel about that
well you can figure that out for
yourself maybe it didn't matter but
probably it mattered
probably you'd like to have that happen
a lot more
but i think even more so the feeling
that you get when you have a
responsibility and you deliver on it
i think that for me that feels even more
meaningful that you uphold your end of
the bargain that you
make someone's life better
that feels even better than when someone
says thank you for that thank you for
doing that right right right no dude
absolutely no i wasn't thinking so much
about the consequences of the thanks
that's just an indication that you did
something you know that was that was
productive and useful and
and
and caring let's say and yeah
i
and i think people know that too that
when they're operating properly
that's well parents find tremendous
meaning in
in the service they provide to their
children obviously
and i think you find that within a
relationship what you give
i mean there's it's reciprocal obviously
there has to be reciprocity but
but it's better to concentrate
at least half the time on what you're
giving right
so perhaps more than that
if we were to i might use a silly
example just like build it out but i
really wanna i really wanna know what
would the world look like if your work
was done
but maybe in a in a visual way if you
were if we were to like build
build let's just call it a commune or
let's start over with the world but the
commune seems like much more accessible
from a thought standpoint because we
could build one of those what would that
look like like how would we create
that environment to
encourage such a high level of harmony
and balance
that the system operates
smooth and
well and everyone is happy like you to
say happy it just happens like how do we
get how do we have happy happen more
often
well
when when we tried to solve that problem
practically that's when we came up with
the writing exercises that i described
it's like i don't think that
young people
in especially in later days in well in
junior high high school maybe even
earlier than that
are
taught enough
to think about what they want and how
they would go about getting it and i
mean what they want in a deep sense like
how their friendships could be better
how their relationships with their
parents could be better how their life
could be better
practically speaking
so we tried to design a program to help
younger people do the self-authoring
program but
my health interfered with that and it
fell by the wayside unfortunately but
it's helpful for people to take stock of
themselves and to chart a course and i
don't think our education system does a
very good job of helping people develop
a
vision of themselves a story for
themselves
and it's a problem because it also means
that they're not ennobled or encouraged
the way they should
be
and i've seen this all constantly
during my lectures that people are so
happy to be encouraged
they're often met with skepticism and
said and i think that's part of the
problem with what's happening in our
culture politically too is that you know
there's this terrible critique of our
culture that it's
all its institutions are fundamentally
predicated on arbitrary power
the exercise of arbitrary power
and that implies that
the ambitions of people who wish to join
that culture and to thrive
are expressions of tyrannical oppressive
arbitrary power
it's very demoralizing to young people
and i don't believe it's true
because i don't think the fundamental
motivation is to exploit others
i think that people who do that fail
generally speaking
uh often precipitously
societies that organize themselves
around that principle
are miserable and collapse
it's full they're they're full of deceit
and backstabbing and distrust it's hell
and so
i think that people are
young people are best encouraged
and that means that you actually have to
you have to sort of like them
like you're a mentor it's like i'm
really on your i'm the on the side of
the good in you and i hope it manifests
itself and i think that's what trust is
for by the way
you know you should trust other people
why
they can bite
why would you trust them well because
it's courageous too
and that way you elicit the best from
them at least that's the best
opportunity you have
you're going to get hurt sometimes
you're going to get hurt distrusting too
but societies without trust are hell on
earth so
trust me that's for sure next generation
though starts with
you having it in the first place
right that's sort of passing along those
patterns is if i don't trust anyone i'm
going to instill that in my child like
the world's not to be trusted
well you can try to change that you know
and if you know that trust is courage
that can help
because well trust can be just naivety
i trust you because i'm too foolish to
know the difference you know i've never
been hurt i've never encountered someone
malevolent so i'm naive and i trust
that's not trust
that's
blind faith in an environment that's
been too benevolent for your own good
but trust that's more like
well we'll think the best to you to
begin with and see what happens
and then if you make a mistake well
we'll deal with that and we'll go back
to trust
and those are stable negotiating
strategies
and so
that's
young people need to be confronted with
that and then they need to be helped to
chart their course
and
that's hard you know it takes a fair bit
of individual attention
because people are so complicated but
well i think what's interesting is how
and i think this is beautiful how it's
it's an inside job like it's the it's
what's going on inside of you that
creates the environment around you like
when i said build the build the commune
you didn't talk about the school you
didn't talk about government you didn't
talk about outside structures you talked
about your own
yeah well that's another thing that we
could talk about too is like
one of the real advantages i think a lot
of the current political movements are
quasi religions essentially and
religious structures have collapsed very
badly and so these things arise to take
their place
because we need a religious
structure because that's what provides
us with our fundamental story
the fundamental story of life is a
religious story by definition that's
that's what i mean by that is the most
fundamental story you have is the
closest thing you have to a religion
so we started there i mean we started
with the stories
yes yes well and metaphysics be damned
but you know i don't know what the
fundamental significance of
consciousness is so and neither does
anybody else so there's plenty of room
for metaphysical speculation it's hard
to know what each person's destiny is
but
in any case
the problem with so many ideological
stories is that they give you an easy
enemy
and that's extremely dangerous and maybe
the enemy they always give you an enemy
yeah that's a real problem
is that that seems like one of the
biggest problems is there's always an
enemy
well the biggest problem is the enemy
isn't you
you're your worst enemy
i agree that's the right place to start
and so
you know one of the advantages i think
of christianity although i don't think
it's limited to christianity is that it
insists that
that's the battleground
you
right and so if you if you need an enemy
and maybe you do
look within
and what's the alternative well to
identify someone else is the enemy
and so what does that leave you with
you're all good nothing you do is wrong
even if you go after them well maybe you
should go after them well we know where
that ends up
i think that's the pattern i think
that's that's the human that's like the
human pattern
the human pattern might be that if you
don't go after the enemy within you go
after the enemy without it's possible
that that's how how we're structured
and it takes a long time to have the
bravery to go after the one within
yeah well the monsters in there are
pretty large
so
yeah and they do get bigger i love the
analogy when you talk about slay the
dragon when it's young little right and
don't let that dragon become
huge and a huge problem and it's going
to be a lot harder to slay that and then
maybe first before that even a lot
harder to even just want to face it
yeah well you know conflict avoided
tends to multiply
not always sometimes it's better to shut
up i mean my wife and i had a rule we
tried to abide by it
the first time something happens that
you don't like you don't say anything
the second time it happens you notice
the third time you bring up all three
times
well then you have the facts in order
and you're not always you're not always
flying off at the handle
i like that
yeah well it
it worked when we were able to implement
it
and then
well then we'd try to settle it
try to negotiate a solution so that we
were both content with
try to solve the problem that often
meant a fair bit of digging painful
digging often
you know because god only knows why you
make mistakes especially repeatedly
agreed i mean i'm i've unpacked stuff
from being a child like
you know
five
ten years old probably before that even
and that's to me where i've found i've
been able to unlock my own patterns as
being able to get that deep but man it
is a it is a maze to get there i mean
it's right there but it is like it might
as well be
on the other side of the world
mm-hmm yeah so well and you often don't
want to figure it out either because
it's painful so if you have the three
rule if those are the rules for the
relationship if what would be
um you know three rules three rules i
know you have 12 rules twice i know you
have 24 rules
but if you were to pick you know
three rules for life that would
lead you down a better path
what would they be
well i think
not saying things you know to be untrue
that's a good thing don't lie
that's good
be grateful
and then
try to work for the best in yourself and
other people
and maybe even broader than that try to
work for the best despite your cynicism
and resentment
i suppose that's a form of gratitude as
well that's what love means
fundamentally is working for the best of
things
that's a
it's a it's a goal
and what's the alternative hate
and that's not going to make things
better it's going to make things worse
oh you know generally speaking
so
something like truth nested inside of
love
then there's gratitude lurking around
the edges
beauty is important
more art right
yeah well more beauty period everywhere
that would be nice
it's kind of intimidating beauty
what do you mean what
what do you mean by that
well because it's an ideal
it judges you
everything i this is something that's
quite interesting is every ideal is a
judge
right
because i feel short of it
yeah but it's an interesting it's an
interesting problem that
you need an ideal to work towards but
the consequence of that is that
you're judged by it that's fascinating
because we always want the ideal right
yeah well i recommend it to people that
they try to reward themselves for
improving over who they were yesterday
rather than punishing themselves from
their deviation for their deviation from
the ideal
look for incremental improvements and
let yourself know that you've managed
them
is it important to hold the ideal but
also then keep short-term goals of yes
against yourself yes definitely
definitely yeah you want to break it
down into and then you do this with kids
too
you want to set someone a task that will
stretch them beyond their limit but not
be impossible right so that's and you
that's that's
part of being intelligent and careful
within a relationship
because you'd it'd be nice to
facilitate success
i mean maybe it has to be punctuated by
failure from time to time but
that's one of the things you do as a
therapist is try to set things up so
that people succeed in moving towards
their goals and try to
make the tasks small enough so that
they're
a reasonable probability
that they will be completed successfully
i think that everyone should have a
therapist so
uh jordan thank you so much for
your time and
i have all your books and um
you're brilliant and i'm super grateful
for this time
yes well thank you very much for talking
to me it's very good of you to take the
time can't wait for further books and
it was really nice talking to you and to
all the people that are listening yeah
thank you thank you very much
my pleasure thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button